beautiful bays crystal-clear water and
mild temperatures all year round the
east coast of Cyprus is a favorite
destination for seaside vacationers one
of the islands most idyllic beaches is
victory Bay a lot of people comes from
everywhere to see their area here they
come to victory
I have their waters for since 1975 I
used to be in the middle of the beach I
used to have one boat one pedal one
candle and pure windsurfing works that's
it
now you see
those who want a bit of culture head
Southwest to the port city of Larnaca
the main landmark of your quarter the
ninth century Church of st. Lazarus
Hotels lined the promenade along finis
Cody's beach
named for the palm trees planted along
the shore boat rides leave the harbor
for an underwater tourist attraction the
xenovia is the largest wreck in the
mediterranean that can be reached by
scuba it's sank in 1980 just two
kilometers of Larnaca with more than 100
trucks on board people travel from other
countries to visit Shinobi is full of
groupers barracudas the marine life down
there is amazing we are talking about
the wreck love is 180 meters so we talk
about the mountain of steel under the
water it's something unique for Tigers
oh I'm quite nervous because it's so
deep all the participants have to prove
they've taken a certain number of scuba
diving hours to be allowed to explore
the synovium
even the pros have to make the dive with
an instructor the more experienced
divers can go all the way down to the
hold of their Zenobia at a depth of 40
meters novices stay near the shipwreck
surface at about 15 meters deep huge
further inland there's plenty more to
discover Cypress has the most extensive
forest of any Mediterranean island at
the foot of the tree Rosemount UNS lion
number of idyllic villages one of the
oldest is La fou with its typical stone
houses and narrow alleys
here they brew coffee according to
Cypriot tradition in a copper pot on a
bed of hot sand
[Music]
a few kilometers away wineries produce
one of the oldest wines in the world
command area it's a sweet wine made
nowhere else but here for almost three
thousand years when the grape is very
sweet we harvest the grapes we lay under
the strong Sun in those days that is
really strong sunlight for eight to ten
days the Sun the grains will lose a lot
of moisture because of evaporation and
after we collect and take to the winery
where we crush and take the juice
immediately the Sun drawing of the
grapes gives the wine its amber color
it's higher alcohol content also means
it keeps for a longer period of time
after a wine tasting it's worth it to
take a trip to the west to Aphrodite's
rock this is where the goddess of love
is said to have emerged from the sea one
of many legends surrounding the site
[Music]
we heard about the legend and you're
supposed to swim three times clockwise
three times counterclockwise and you'll
be young forever
we haven't learned yeah we haven't done
it yet so tomorrow
according to another variant couples who
swim around the rock will be blessed
with eternal love and even if the
eternal love or eternal youth doesn't
work out you'll still be rewarded with a
spectacular sunset